[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how confidential
VMs and GKE Nodes
can help you protect data
while it is being processed.
Google Cloud automatically
encrypts your data
in transit and at rest
and employs a variety
of isolation and
sandboxing techniques
in our infrastructure to
help make our multitenant
architecture secure.
We also offer a service for you
to manage your own encryption
keys if desired.
However, for
application developers
who want to add another layer
of protection for their data,
we offer confidential computing.
Confidential computing
provides virtual machines
that encrypt your data
in memory and elsewhere
outside the central
processing unit, or CPU,
so that you can further isolate
your workloads in the Cloud.
And if you are automating
your application's deployment
through Kubernetes
containers, you
can also enforce the use
of Confidential GKE Nodes
so that all your workloads
running on these nodes
are encrypting sensitive
code and other data
while in use, since the
container orchestrator
Google Kubernetes Engine is
built on top of the Compute
Engine platform.
Confidential GKE
Nodes also leverage
shielded GKE Nodes to offer
protection against rootkit
and bootkits, helping to ensure
the integrity of the operating
system you run on.
To set up Confidential
VMs, first
enable the Compute Engine API
via your Google Cloud Console
or via the
command-line terminal.
Next, from the console, you
can create a VM instance
and expand the CPU
Platform and GPU section,
and then enable the
Confidential Computing service.
Once the VM is created,
you can click SSH into it
and interact with your
Confidential VM instance.
To set up Confidential
GKE Nodes,
you enable the Google
Kubernetes Engine API.
Next, create your VMs and
decide what zone and region
you would like them in.
Then enable the Confidential
GKE Nodes in a new cluster.
After you create a Confidential
GKE cluster, all the nodes
and node pools you create
will be confidential.
Since Google's approach
to confidential computing
is to make it easy to add
protection for existing
applications, the GKE
workloads that you presently
run today can run on
Confidential GKE Nodes
without code changes.
You can also optionally
declaratively express
that your workloads must
only run on clusters
with Confidential GKE Nodes.
Confidential VMs do
have their own pricing.
If you enable Confidential GKE
Nodes, there is no extra cost.
However, there are
more logs produced.
So if you want
additional protection
for your compute workloads,
check out Confidential VMs
and Confidential GKE Nodes.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/confidential
computing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]